after much anticipation it is here God's
Deadpool juicy little trailer filled
with clues and Easter Egg juice for you
and we're here to drink it to the last
drop
I'm Gabe Hall writer Oh stick around
we've got a tease for the Deadpool
sequel at the end so you'll want to see
that this is hashtag news now Deadpool
is a Marvel comic book hero with a
history both in comics and you may not
remember it but in film two x-men
origins so after this take a click over
to our other video to get a better idea
of who this guy is and what happened
with this character the last time they
tried it now because we're all adults
here we're gonna watch the red band
trailer but don't worry we'll include
some stuff on the green band to put on
to the trailer the trailer opens with
Wade Wilson aka Deadpool and his
girlfriend Vanessa played by Morena
Baccarin
a firefly hotness with Wade learning he
has terminal cancer now a mysterious
figure comes to make him an offer he
can't refuse you might know this creepy
actor as the creepy alien and Galaxy
Quest we meet the recruiter he works for
the Weapon X program which is the same
group that gave Wolverine has adamantium
claws oh you guys will CG and the claws
right we don't have the budget for that
are you kidding me so wait wait wait
does that mean Deadpool ties in with the
x-men and Wolverine
we're not over to our other video that
has a quick rundown on all that okay
make you a superhero you just promise
you'll do right by me
sure buddy we'll do right by you and by
right you mean completely ruin your life
and make you into a government super
weapon that will do whatever we want
with you that's what you mean by right
on the left side here you can see some
of the other patients being carted
around with what looks like a neck brace
just speculating here but this could be
Worm a fellow experiment and Deadpool's
only friend while he was inside the lab
please don't make the supersuit green or
animated haha yes Ryan right here this
is a callback to his Green Lantern
costume which was completely CG which is
pretty weird choice all around people
hated that costume but it's a good
example of how the character of Deadpool
doesn't give a flying Floop about
calling out our reality even though it
breaks the fourth wall what's the
definition for fall right there huh
don't even have to look in the
dictionary dictionary come hug guys guys
plural form of guy right come on stop it
let's move on a director Tim Miller
confirmed that Wade Wilson will not
break the fourth wall but his alter-ego
of Deadpool can do it
all the time because Deadpool knows he's
in a movie but Wade Wilson doesn't the
director also said that Ryan Reynolds
couldn't help but go off about how much
beef he had with the Green Lantern movie
that there's bound to be lots of Wade
Wilson almost breaking the fourth wall
just so Ryan can vent out all that Green
Lantern angst but you might have to
watch the deleted blu-ray scenes to see
it all through one thing that never
survives this place is a sense of humor
we meet a Jay house who seems to be the
primary villain of the movie now in the
comics Ajax is a sadistic Weapon X
operative who's had his nerves burned
out due to experimentation fun note he's
being played by Ed screen's who was on
Game of Thrones as the original Daario
naharis before he quit the freakin show
to do transporter begins whatever
they're calling it yeah I'm gonna shoot
baby up until now it's been sort of a
moody dour superhero trailer but once
salt-n-pepa's shoot kicks in you know
you're in for a ride in the original
version of this scene it was all a bad
girl but Deadpool was listening to it if
you're wondering what I mean by the
original version I'll get to that in a
second
if you look at Wade's mask you'll note
that it's actually CG in a lot of shots
this is to preserve how incredibly
expressive Deadpool can be through his
mattes Deadpool dropping off the highway
into the sunroof of this moving SUV
shows off his incredible ninja skills
that with a Z on the end can I just know
how much I love it when trailer sound
effects line up to the music it's like
scratching an itch I didn't even know I
had but if all this feels really
familiar that's because it's the exact
highway sequence from the leaked
Deadpool animatic last year that
actually wasn't a leaked scene from this
movie that was a proof-of-concept that
Ryan Reynolds actually pushed to make
happen so that he could show what a good
Deadpool movie would look like instead
of that crappy treatment he got on x-men
origins
people love that proof of concept so
much that that's the entire reason they
even made this movie and that original
scene was so great they just kept it
mostly as is in the film there's a link
in the description to it if you want to
check the full thing out if you look at
the street signs they're listed as 'no
cheesy f bobby on which is the
co-creator of Deadpool's name reversed
and the Miller signed to the right is
probably for Tim Miller the director how
not vein of it really Tim didn't put
enough of your stamp on the film behind
the scenes just get over your set from
the skyline we can tell that this is
pretty obviously Vancouver which also
makes sense because a lot of Deadpool's
origin takes place in Canadian
government facilities this guy's got the
right idea he wore the brown pants the
brown pants is a unique little reference
to poop
he's talking about poop good awesome
shot here of Deadpool CGI's also of note
his dentals gun it looks like a desert
eagle handgun and it's the official gun
of characters like Agent Smith from the
matrix and Laura Croft from trim Raider
if you need a quick way to let viewers
know that your character is a badass
this is it it's also the bane of my
online shooter existence two guys with
one bullet
what Deadpool's got you beat this moment
of the green band trailer here the music
which is another typical Deadpool
fourth-wall shatter and then the editor
plays DMX's dog give it to which has to
be a little nod here because Deadpool
was created by Weapon X and we'll give
it to you it being deaf deadpool showing
off his ability to really take a hit but
also an example of a womb that doesn't
faze him since he has regenerative
healing due to all the government
experimentation thanks Obama much like
Wolverine from the x-men Deadpool has
healed himself back from being sliced
diced and even decapitated since you
guys are stepping out could you grab me
a couple chimichangas
so to the skull that's part one of how
you earn an r-rating now while I have no
doubt that gina carano herself could
probably lift me up with one arm this
does sort of hinted her having some sort
of super strength and if you're reading
the words during the section which let's
be honest you were probably distracted
they say with great power comes great
irresponsibility lay on spider-man's
catchphrase with great power comes great
responsibility
let's just freeze frame on this for a
second no not just to get an eyeful of
the steam eNOS going on there but about
the decorations and lights in the
background that combined with the
decorations in a later scene suggests
that this is a Christmas movie - to king
stefan's sex and our ratings oh yeah
here we go
freaking Colossus of x-men Fame the
strongman mutant who can turn himself
into metal shows up in what I hope isn't
just a cameo who else in this movie has
shown super strength less angry Rosie
O'Donnell Gina Carano yes is Gina Carano
got an MMA fight Colossus one can only
hope one being me
I'm the one fans of Colossus might also
note that this one looks a lot Rican
bigger than the previous Colossus and
that's because the director was not down
with how puny he seemed in the x-men
movies before he's like seven and a half
feet tall here a super quick clip of
brianna hildebrand playing negasonic
teenage warhead fans lucky enough to
have seen the leaked comic-con footage
got to see her introduce herself and get
a quick pep talk from deadpool negasonic
teenage warhead is primarily another
x-men character and doesn't actually
tend to have crossover with Deadpool but
the writers just thought it'd be funny
to have a goth teen be a straight man
sidekick to Colossus I think they were
right what is she gonna call herself
when she turns 20 negasonic college-age
warhead it reeks like old lady pants in
here sounds like you have a dick in your
mouth scene with more Christmas decor
but also we meet blind owl Deadpool's
elderly blind roommate they kind of have
a weird relationship considering
Deadpool was sent to kill her but then
later kidnapped her but then they became
friends and now she's kind of his
housekeeper basically the same story as
Alice in the Brady Bunch
Oh [ __ ] you are hard to look at
like a testicle with teeth hey dead puss
face the results of the experiment that
cured his cancer also left him forever
looking scarred look like Freddy Krueger
face-fucked a topographical map of Utah
exactly yeah that checks out this is TJ
Miller from Silicon Valley and a weasel
Deadpool's arms dealer and info
it's also good to have a friend who will
tell you like it is
and the trailer money shot we get to see
a nice close-up trippy turtle as well as
Deadpool's snort his Gunsmoke and while
smoking is bad this shot is still very
very cool but again don't smoke kids now
this thing doesn't come in until after
February but hey it's at least a lot
closer than the sequel right oh speaking
of the sequel the director let it spill
that in Deadpool - they most certainly
will feature another major character
from Deadpool comics and the Marvel
world cable cable is the son of Cyclops
and a clone of being gray but he's also
a time traveler from the future so he's
kind of old and my gosh are they gonna
make such a great buddy comedy together
I can't wait until Deadpool - okay if
you need more Deadpool now's a good time
to click over to our who is Deadpool
breakdown video just to keep the
conversation going and chat about how
awesome it is that we have an
incarnation this character on film that
doesn't have his frickin mouth sewn shut
let's get some conversation going in the
comments guys I want to hear what you
think do you think there's any chance
we'll get some more Deadpool crossover
with any other characters his old buddy
Wolverine wants to work with him again I
hear great stuck in an elevator with
five guys I calculate a [ __ ] up he'll
join the fun guys subscribe we're here
all day all week all month all of our
lives we don't have a choice so just
come be a part of the fun I'm Gabe hole
writer and I have regenerative healing
abilities - hey Ted punch me in the face
No hey come on dude why not you have
muscles yeah that's true but do it
anyway punch me okay guys 10 10 feet
from the stress of hitting me in the
face Hey